what do you know about what kinda  textiles Shepherds cool outfits all the  front  how much more you hiding feelings about  panther but films equally about Wakanda  what seats of Chavez French people we  ask the answer to you know when he's  sitting on that throne where commas  wounds have been up since its inception  it's the best-kept secret in the world  because they have something that once  they have this natural resource the kind  of thrives off of they minded things in  technology it's very sought-after by  anybody who's ever come in contact with  it  Black Panther has to look out for an  entire nation and also consider that  nation's place and how they affect the  rest of the world to see an African  country with kings and queens and  warriors it's so inspiring it's just an  incredible world to occupy  you